he animated hit Zootopia won a boatload
of awards and critical acclaim and for
good reason the movie was pretty much
fantastic from start to finish but that
doesn't mean it was an easy path to
success fine we'll have to do this the
hard way some creative shake ups late in
the game - a few interesting moves
during the marketing campaign here's the
untold truth of Disney's Zootopia darker
early draft the world of Zootopia wasn't
always quite so cheery it was reported
that an early draft of the script
presented the city as broken with a
veneer of utopia but a dark dystopian
truth underneath the problem
well this version of Zootopia didn't
really feel like a place a person would
actually want to visit and the studio's
worried viewers wouldn't connect to the
city if it wasn't a place they fell in
love with they backed off that approach
which led to the vibrant and gorgeous
Zootopia we ended up getting Kristen
Bell's slow cameo actress Kristen Bella
is a bit on the quirky side and
apparently one of the greatest
obsessions is sloths this obsession
became very public when a husband Dax
Shepard surprised her with the news that
a sloth would be at a birthday party and
she was so excited that she had a
complete emotional meltdown
the video of the actresses freaked out
quickly became a viral sensation it was
such a big deal that word go back to the
Zootopia team and they reached out to
belvera cameo as the voice of the lady
sloth Priscilla
shifting protagonists the story at the
heart of Zootopia is fairly unique for a
Disney flick and it turns out that it
actually changed a lot during the latter
part of production instead of telling
the story from the perspective of
do-gooder Judi Hawks the original story
largely took place from the viewpoint of
the wily phox Nick Wilde director Byron
Howard explained that the story took a
huge shift midstream because it was hard
to actually like Nick how had also made
it clear that he wanted audiences to
start to fall so Nick at the same time
as Judi does and that proved difficult
when he was presented as the hero from
the get-go local newscasters for the
most part utopia was pretty much the
same film no matter which country on
market you watched it in but there was
one subtle change that most people
didn't even know about the animal
newscaster Disney tailored the character
to animals that were popular and a good
fit for each country in the US and
Canada we saw a moose in Japan it was a
tanuki Australia got a koala and China
it was a panda this is the cool thing to
do but most people would never even have
noticed it unless they went on a
worldwide tour of Zootopia viewings
Shakira's kirby demands this is a disney
movie after all so of course it had to
be true a catchy musical number that
fell to real-life singer Shakira who
voiced the animal popstar gazelle and
gave us the hit song try everything
budge Gera also had some cool when it
came to a characters look the early
drawings of gazelle were apparently very
skinny
so Shakira asked the designers to give
her characters
Disney obliged and we ended up getting a
gazelle whose hips were incapable of
telling falsehoods Nick's middle name in
Zootopia the slide the lovable fox next
full name is actually Nicholas P wild
but what the heck does the P stand for
director Byron Howard revealed Nick's
middle name is officially Pye Beria's
which is a subtle nod to Captain James
Kirk middle name Tiberius but have a
lack of these two characters really it's
called a hustle sweetheart and I'm not
the liar he is
look Frank I was taking over a whole
ball of wax and you cooperate with us
and maybe we'll cut you in for a piece
of the action now that you mention it
Nick does have a bit of that same urges
John Carter the team behind this film
took their world building
responsibilities seriously to the point
of bringing in automotive design legend
Jay Mays to help develop the concepts to
the different designs that all these
berries animal species might drive what
would a graph car look like or hippos
SUV those were the type of questions the
filmmakers put to mate the designer took
his jobs seriously and made sure that
each of the vehicles scene in the film
properly represented the animals they
were carrying a sense of scale the
design team used accurate scales to
excellent effect for some amazing action
set-pieces in in Zootopia but even more
went into those scenes than most may
have realized every single animal
represented in Zootopia is made to scale
meaning the rabbits match up just like
they should win standing beside a lion
and a giraffe really is that much bigger
than a fox that design work even makes
it into the world itself with different
areas and buildings designed for
specific types of animals Disney Easter
eggs a Disney movie about a world of
walking talking animals is a veritable
playground for Easter eggs and this one
took full advantage it would take a
while to name them all but here are a
few your calendar hanger
the wall in chief bogos office speeches
a shot of San fransokyo from big hero
six another scene features two elephant
kids ice-skating in frozen absence and
several Disney flicks get the scoop
treatment of the weasels bootleg DVD
cases the backlash at this point is not
really a secret to anyone that while the
movie is a lot of fun
Zootopia also tells a very poignant
story about racial messaging nature
urban nurture and the way we judge
others it may have something to do with
biology what do you mean I hardly but
that high-minded approach to a kids
movie didn't see it well with everyone
Zootopia was met with a bit of backlash
once the film became a major hit but
some pundits calling it a muddled mess
and accusing the film of taking itself
too seriously we aren't sure how founded
these complaints really were a Zootopia
definitely had no trouble receiving
acclaim come award season a very
friendly though Disney films are
typically marketed to families the
studio took a very sneaky route to
promote Zootopia to one very specific
subculture very if you don't know
furries are folks who'd like to dress up
as animals and well get together to have
a good time
apparently Disney contracted a marketing
firm to promote the film to three stand
groups with a plan to encourage them to
tweet and share their own photos using
film specific hashtags yes
Twitter exploded Twitter itself Disney
never actually acknowledged the play but
the paper trail definitely seemed to
prove it was true regardless the film
was a huge hit so oh maybe a work
funnily enough isn't the first time
talking animals and how to clash with
eatable on screen my friends call me
sexy oh lucky you thanks for watching
click the loop break on to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
you